thank you very much and hi everybody so
why am i standing here today and I
didn't know whether there would be a
little introduction usually when people
go through my CV they forget to mention
my very first job which is actually the
one I'm most proud of which was vomiting
floppy disks at the computer store of my
dad when I was six years old so I've
been interested in technology and
digitization my whole life I'd say but I
started working on the ethics of
algorithms which is the project I'm
leading at the Met it's much different
not because of my interest and
Technology are not solely because of
that but actually because I'm interested
in human decision making and the flaws
of human decision-making and how human
biases are introduced into societal
structures and how those in turn
reinforce human biases and there's well
as as humans we like to feel like these
super rational beings and we know from
cognitive sciences that we are
everything but just rational we are led
by the weather our personal experiences
our moods and fortunately stereotypes
whether we like it or not and I started
working on this issue because I actually
am convinced that automated
decision-making can help us make more
efficient more consistent and also
fairer decision decisions and that it
can help us create a more equal society
however as you all know obviously
algorithms aren't like falling from the
sky they made by humans and they can
contain mistakes they can reproduce
biases by the people who use them who
decide over they use who set their goals
who interprets the outputs by
algorithmic decision-making and they can
actually scale human biases and make
things even worse than before and
usually my audiences I have to convince
them more of the upper
Unity's that lie in using the technology
particularly when you're in Germany
people are rather techno skeptic and I
believe that today I have a bit of a
different job I would like to show you
some examples that show that the line
between good and bad is often a very
thin one and that also show that we need
to look at codes through the way it is
actually embedded in the social economic
context some of you might have heard
that Amazon started I think it was in
2018 to use an algorithmic system to
automate part of their hiring process
and first of all I thought wow this
sounds really like a great idea because
we still know that the labor market is
one of the most unfair parts of society
for example in Germany when you apply
for a job with a non German sounding
name your chance of being declined Rises
by 50% however shortly after they
started this trial they realized that
the system was consistently rejecting
women who applied for jobs at Amazon and
it's quite clear that here the problem
wasn't actually the code it was the data
the system was trained with which was
actually data on current Amazon
employees from the past 10 years and as
you might know Amazon just like most big
tech companies employees are to a large
extent still male I think it's about 20
percent actually of people and technical
roles that are female so the system was
trained on this data I had learned this
bias and started rejecting women and
even when the gender variables were
removed from the CVS it learned to pick
up there through proxy variables the
information on the gender for example
because people attended specific tool
schools that were only for women you
might also know actually another example
that I like to use a lot is from the
field of facial recognition where an MIT
student about a year ago joyboy land
weenie I really recommend watching her
TED talk she was working on the quality
of facial rec
and she realized that her own face
couldn't be detected by any of the
systems she was working with and why was
that because she's a woman and because
she's black and she found out that IBM
face plus plus and Microsoft's facial
recognition systems work much better on
men than they do on women and on white
people than they do on people of color
my next example brings us to France
where back in 2009 the French Ministry
of Education started to automate the
matching process of students to
universities and this of course is a
process that's really prone for
automation however the problem was that
the way the matching happened and the
criteria that were being used for this
matching process were kept secret in the
u.s. these the use of these kind of
systems had been really successful in
increasing the happiness of university
students parents however in France it
started evoking criticism among students
because they wanted to know what was
actually behind the system what kind of
values were leading the matching and
based on the French Freedom of
Information Law they sued the French
ministry to open up the code and what
started was a legal side that went on
until 2017 and in 2017 they finally won
and Fanny note on the side what the
French ministry did was they printed out
the code and send it by a post to the
student union
thanks again to a lot of volunteers that
they found through github they were able
to read it ties it and what they found
out was that one of the key factors for
matching students to universities was
actually the proximity of the address to
the to the universities address and if
you know a little bit about the French
education system you might know that all
the elite universities actually located
in like fancy areas around the center of
Paris so this system was reproducing
social discrimination and here this is a
super simple rule-based matching
it wasn't the complexity of the
technology there's usually this
narrative of the black box algorithm
that we cannot understand because of its
technical complexity this was not the
issue the issue was actually the
narrative that was created around this
black box problem and a conscious
decision to keep the system secret due
to trade secrets
due to maybe worries that it might evoke
protests my last example brings us to
Australia where the Ministry of Social
Welfare started using a system to detect
discrepancies between income reports and
information they held on social welfare
money that was received by people when a
discrepancy was identified by the system
it sent out automated warning mails to
people and the idea behind using the
system was to increase the efficiency of
finding the people that were receiving
well were wrongly receiving welfare
money so this actually could be in the
interest of whole society you save tax
money and they were pretty successful in
ramping up the efficiency they sent out
200,000 of these warning letters within
a week something they would have needed
a whole year before and in the testing
phase 200 thousands of these warning
letters were sent out to people shortly
before Christmas stating well we like to
inform you that you owe the stage 16
thousand euro and what they found out
was 20,000 of these 200,000 emails that
were sent out were actually wrong
so people were asked to pay a lot of
money start paying tomorrow and they
were not informed that there was an
automated system behind it they were not
informed how they came to the decision
and they were not really offered any
forms of Appeal and the Ministry that
had used the system because of its
efficiency at the same time was not
prepared for this backlash and they
weren't aware that efficiency also means
that mistakes scale
and actually if you go on Twitter today
it's been three years since they started
using the systems and you look for the
hashtag not my depth or Robo debt you
can still find stories of people who
haven't found justice who are left alone
and where the burden of proof is moved
from the ministry to those people
affected by these mistakes what these
three cases show is like I said that the
thin line between a system that's used
with a good purpose that can actually
create more harm than good is often a
fine one and that it's not enough to
just look at the code we also need to
look at the data that's being used to
program it we need to look at the
underlying goals behind the system what
values went into it and we need to look
at how it is embedded and well something
I should maybe mention in all our work
is that of course when I talk of
algorithmic decision making algorithms I
don't mean the system that's used to
sort screws in an industry or the one
that's recommending you what dress to
buy what I'm talking about algorithmic
decision-making systems I mean those
that I used in areas that have a
profound impact on people's lives in the
debates of how to create more ethical
algorithmic decision-making there has
been one idea going around for quite a
while it's the one of creating
professional ethics codes for
programmers such as the Hippocratic oath
for in medicine or the press code in for
journalists and we thought about this
and we felt like this was actually short
of the complexity of the development and
the examples I just showed you well they
basically underlined this thought
because they show that it's not enough
to focus on the code alone so what we
did instead is we came up with a
process-oriented set of rules the argu
rules which we developed together with
the berlin based think tank I rights lab
and those nine principles which I will
present to you shortly
address everybody
who's involved in the development
process and the use of algorithmic
decision-making so people who are the
decision-makers and actually decide
whether a system will be used at all and
what kind of values will go into the
system what it should be optimized for
people who create the code but also
those who collect and categorize the
data also people who design how an
output of an algorithmic system will
actually be presented because a lot of
these systems in the areas such as
education health and security actually
assistant system so at the end of the
decision-making process there's still a
human that gets a prediction that say
and uses that to make the final decision
and the way the algorithmic system
presents its output has a profound
effect on how independent that person
remains in their decision making process
because we address such a very diverse
group of people who have also very
different levels of understanding of the
technological bits or the socio-economic
bits this was really a challenge because
we wanted to create rules that were as
concrete as possible while being well
understandable for this whole group of
people and we tried to do so by
involving as many and as diverse people
as possible we formed an diverse expert
group we conducted surveys we had an
open survey where around 300 people
participated and actually think there
are some people in this room here who
are part of this process and we're
really thankful because the creation of
the Argos was really a joint effort and
it is until today and now I need like a
dramatic drumroll because here they are
those are the nine alga rules they're
not perfect they're not final they never
will be they're actually open for
everybody to use them to adjust them to
their purposes to try apply them and
make them fit and I think what they
really are is a start for discussion
among different people in an
organization and I want to walk through
them real quickly
the first one strengths and competency
what we see often times and particularly
in the public sector where a lot of
these application fields happen is that
the people who decide over the use of
the system don't really know how they
work and now the other hand the people
who design these systems might not be
aware of the social impact they might
have so what we need is more for
conversation between the different
stakeholders involved and competency
building on both sides this is also
necessary for the second rule define
responsibility before a system is being
used it needs to be clear who's
responsible for which parts we also
demand rule number three that impact
assessments happen before a system is
being used in the three cases I gave you
it is pretty clear that people's lives
are affected by these systems but there
might be other areas of application
where when you look at it at first this
might not be so clear and only when you
think for example of possible side
effects you might become aware that this
is actually having ethical implications
guarantees security I think that one is
pretty self-explanatory provide labeling
you might realize that one of the big
buzz words of the debate transparency
does not appear anywhere and we
consciously decided actually against
using it because transparency can mean
so many different things and it depends
a lot on who transparency is provided
for what kind of systems it is used for
and in what part of the development
process so we tried to narrow it down by
saying we need labeling we when I when
an algorithmic system decides over
whether I get access to university maybe
what kind of treatment I get in the
hospital I need to know so I need to
know when a person actually used
predictive algorithm to make their
decision secondly this is another
dimension of transparency we need to
ensure intelligibility we could also
call this explained ability so we need
to try to make the way this decision was
made understandable to those affected
and this one doesn't only have a
technological dimension it's actually
a lot about cognitive science and we
know from data protection that's where
we just open information to people this
might not really lead to an increase of
the understanding because there's this
phenomenon called information overload a
lot of people actually don't read when
you provide them with information of how
the data is being used so it's really
key to consider how much time people
have how much knowledge they have on how
the system works and make things as
understandable as possible safeguard
manageability I think in the development
process this was probably the criteria
that changed the most
at the beginning we we felt that there
should be the opportunity to kind of
make a wrong decision and happen but of
course that's not always possible when a
car goes against a tree you can't make
that unhappen so this criteria became
manageability which basically means that
you should always have the opportunity
to switch off a system if something's
going wrong to detect what made it go
wrong and to change that monitoring
impacts something else these cases
showed that oftentimes the impact only
becomes visible once they're being
implemented and once they're being used
by the people who work with the systems
so it's not enough to do like impact
assessment before using the systems but
you have to do it on a regular basis
particularly if your system is a dynamic
one and it changes and the last one
which I think became pretty clear in the
Australian case you need to establish
complaint mechanisms if you inform
people about a system making decisions
about them if you make it intelligible
this doesn't really help them if they
don't have a way to actually complain
when something went wrong at the moment
we are actually working on making sure
that these rules are also being applied
because it's great to put them out there
and to say to people you can use them
but it won't have much of an impact if
we don't work towards the implementation
so we're in an experimental phase here
at the moment we're seeing whether
they can be integrated into a quality
criteria catalog for health apps we are
working on integrating them into the
norming processes standard setting
processes of algorithmic decision-making
systems and we're also asking for public
sector institutions and programmers such
as you designers to help us personalize
them because of course things such as
intelligibility or security mean very
different things depending on whether
you the person writing the code are the
one deciding over the organizational
structures in which the system is being
used so I hope you enjoyed the
presentation and I hope that this was
may be helpful for you for your work
that you can use it to start discussions
with the people you work with to ask
questions because the skills you have
more and more on demands and I think you
should never underestimate the power you
have to also make demands in the
organizations you work for to talk about
these kind of issues I know that there
will be Q&A session I'm happy to go more
into detail on the different rules on
the ways of application and yeah I'm
happy to learn from you as well thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
we do have time for a few questions
yes hello so my first question would be
that you have these rules but you have
any kind of best practice best practices
for them is it available and if it is
where we can find them
good question really important we're
actually collecting best practices at
the moment we've come up with a couple
of them still collecting more so bring
them on and you can find them not now
but probably in a month or two on the al
Ghul's website so go to WWI of the rules
org and you get all the information
there this is also where you can find
our contact address and where you can
submit ideas or best cases yeah thank
you very much for this great
presentation I have seen so many useless
certifications for companies over the
years but this was would be one that I
would really like to see implemented in
a lot of companies are you planning on
doing a certification thing or something
like your progress update for companies
or something they can yes so we're in
well we're talking a lot with I Triple E
with ACM at the moment and a couple of
software companies who are willing to
test these kind of things with us we've
also had the idea of creating like a
matrix system of classifying different
software's based on these rules because
of course depending on the impact the
system has on society you don't need the
same level let's say of explain ability
so we kind of need two approaches we
need a classification of the systems
based on the rules but also based on
their societal impact and if you have
ideas if you have contacts let's let's
have a chat afterwards it's on ah it is
you were talking earlier about how our
girl rules were created as a joint
effort and I was just wondering how did
you ensure that you had diversity within
your own team because I can imagine that
was that's very key to what you're
describing here Thanks well by making it
a topic like by consciously deciding
that diversity should matter by looking
at who's part of the discussion I mean
we had an expert group of around ten
people where we try to make sure that
different academics perspectives and the
room that people without an academic
background are in the room that people
of both genders and the room and of
course we didn't succeed on any levels I
think diversity is really a process and
you can always become better but I think
we did an okay job there and of course
when we opened up the aisle girls in our
survey this is where it becomes tricky
because there's always a self-selection
bias it's people who participate who are
already kind of aware of the issue and
who have the time to deal with this so
this is obviously where it becomes
harder but now that we're testing these
systems we're again trying to involve as
many different people as possible hi
thanks for the great talk I was
wondering are you aware of and I mean
they're loads of examples are you aware
of a monitoring because we always come
across these stories and how they go
wrong and how they affect people but I
haven't come across something that kind
of collects and also it looks at what
happens next
because there might be a company that
makes the mistakes and then trial starts
adopting these are the rules and
actually produces best practices based
on their mistakes it's not always that
things go wrong and then nothing happens
is there kind of like a monitoring
service like that well partly I mean to
some extent the ideas that we put this
out there and that we continue working
on certain fields of implication but
that in other fields we depend on people
to take this on and make it their own
project so we're not definitely not
going to monitor all ways in which the
AG rules are being implemented but
something we've been doing because I
actually agree that there's not enough
exchange of knowledge on what went wrong
what went good how people dealt with
issues we're creating this report called
the automation society report together
with an organization called algorithm
watch you might have heard about it it's
kind of like food watch but for
algorithmic systems and they're also one
of the organizations behind the open
shoe farm project together with the Open
Knowledge Foundation which was a project
that used data donations to make the
shoe fragra the more transparent and
we've published the first version which
collects good and bad examples from
across Europe and makes them available
to the public and we published we're
currently working on a second version of
this report which will be published in
March next year you can go to our blog
ethics of algorithms and you'll find
information there thanks a lot thank you
everybody
we're gonna have the rest of the QA
session upstairs in the lounge please be
mindful that the tutorials are gonna
start at 11:30 and the talks start at
11:50 and please do take your cups and
glasses with you outside the hall thank
you law thank you everybody
[Applause]